hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so for those who don't
know me yet i'm a professional trader
and i'm doing youtube videos where i try
to show you guys everything i know about
technical analysis and about analyzing
financial data
to build up your scenarios and set up
your trades so my videos i try to
explain as good as i can i hope this
helps you guys
so that you can use the same techniques
that i like to use at work to make money
on the markets
so in today's video i want to make a big
update guys on gamestop
and show you some cool option strategies
that you can make
so let's get into it
[Music]
so let me remind you first the situation
so i'm using a lot of idiot wave
counting i associate this with
fibonacci to find my targets i associate
this with trend lines of course which is
the basis
i try to spot the breakouts then i use
the breakout
techniques that i show you guys many
times you wait for confirmation you buy
the retest
using fibs using moving averages using
the trend lines that you have
used to find your breakouts and then you
enter your trades so here
elliot is telling us that you know we
went to 250
now we're consolidating so the
volatility is not very high you can see
that gamestop has a lot of
energy guys a lot of energy all right so
amc
right now i do those two together amc is
the time to wait for me
and to sell maybe corruptions to buy
later
the lowest strike and get a free cold
spread
for gamestop we are not in the same
situation guys
we just had the first wave so now i
think
not sure it's complete or not but it's
going to be complete soon
then we're going to correct and we are
not very high yet we are just above the
breakout level
so it's a actually nice opportunity to
start
loading some calls guys the volatility
is high but it can be much higher as we
can see
for amc so i would actually try to buy
the deep here
around maybe 220 not sure this has
holding out i might have one day
or two delay uh but once again it's not
very important here i'm giving you some
strategies on the longer term
i think that you know 220 it will
probably hold but
you know we need to retest this trend
line sometimes so
eventually it might break i'm not sure
but i would be a buyer here
and i would add some more position at
the 190
i would be basically buying this whole
area guys
so what we can do here guys
is to go on the option market gme
um go on the once again i expect some
moves to come within one or two weeks so
we have some time
but it can come earlier once again maybe
in a few days we're gonna have those
strong moves as well to come so that's
why starting to load some collapsions
right now is actually smart for me okay
so we can go on the july maturity guys
and as i said
what i like to do when we are not far
from the breakup level i like to start
accumulate
some long coal positions so for example
here
i don't like to buy the very out of the
money strikes
this is a valid strategy as well if you
want to get the maximum of
explosivity this is what you need to do
if you want basically if you believe in
the squeeze very soon
the 800 strike is the right strike to
buy even if it's very expensive
in terms of volatility what i like to do
guys is actually to do something
that is more you know close to what i do
at work i would actually buy those
lower strikes maybe around the 400 level
300 so let's go to the 400 level for
example
this one costs 20 right and the 800
costs
780 and then you accumulate
guys some 400 strike calls so let me
show you how this looks
and let me show you the complete
strategy so once again strategy you can
do
in different steps i showed you this
butterfly guys
so this butterfly is still a very nice
strategy to do
500 600 800 butterfly two
by minus three by by one so it's a bit
not symmetrical butterfly
go check my other videos guys for 200
usd you can make 20.
so this is very nice strategy because
you
actually use the fact that the upside
velocity is very high
here let's say we accumulate some 400
strikes
all right so here we have zero zero
let's say we don't have any shares
this cost twenty so this would cost you
let's say you buy one two thousand us
dollar
so i know it's expensive guys i know
it's expensive
but you're gonna see we're gonna
actually bring back this level to
a very more decent premium so you start
buying the 400 strike
and if it goes lower you accumulate so
if it goes lower and then you can find
this price at 15
you buy more it's actually very
expensive but you can buy some fractions
of this
if you go on other exchange on using
some brokers if you don't do it
directly on the exchange and then you're
gonna buy maybe a second
one i don't know but let's say you
accumulate for an average price
of even 17 because you buy some at 20
then maybe if it goes over at
15 and what the strategy consists
in is actually then when the price
action is going to go
higher let's say it takes 50 100 which i
think is gonna happen within two weeks
maximum one month even maybe before
but i think we're gonna have some light
like some correction coming this week
a consolidation at least and then you go
to the 800 strike guys
once this goes higher that hundred
strikes right now cost eight
but if gamestop takes 50 it's gonna cost
probably around 12 or something like
this you know even maybe 13 so let's say
you can sell it at 12 and then you sell
it at 12.
so once again it's a risky strategy
because you're not sure that
if gamestop doesn't go higher you're
just going to lose your premium
so that's a possibility you need to be
aware of that here once again i'm in
july my shooting
so this needs to happen soon but i think
this would happen soon and then
you sell this one and you buy your code
spread for a very decent price
and once again guys look for only 500
usd you can make
up to 40 if gamestop goes to 800 or more
so you might tell me that this scenario
is far for now
but it was far as well for amc and we
did it in one week
so there is a lot of bullish momentum in
this market
so this is the kind of strategy i would
make that i think are very nice because
if you do the call spread
right now guys it costs you twice as
much
as if you do it in different steps but
there is more risk doing it in different
steps but when you
know technical analysis it's actually
easier to
time your entry in this call options you
buy it
when you are close to the breakout
levels and once the move happens you
take some profits by selling
more upside calls benefiting as well
from the volatility
that is going to go higher if the
volatility goes really really high you
can even set it at 17 guys
and get a frequent spread you see
getting a frequent spread is a very nice
move that
you know is not easy but it's very
manageable i can do it like
i i don't succeed each time i'm trying
but i'm usually quite close to frequent
spreads and once you have a frequent
spreads you put it somewhere
and if you scare your happens this is
free money coming
so this is what traders actually do i
mean on the option market
so that's it for me guys i hope this was
interesting for you to
understand how you can actually get a
frequent spread so which is a free
option
on the upside and you can use this
techniques
in different situations if the price
action is already high
you first sell the upside option and
then you're gonna buy the lowest strike
or if the price action is close to a
breakout level like for gamestop
you start by buying accumulating and
once the move happens you
take your profits by selling the higher
strike
so i hope this was clear enough for you
i will do more videos like this
i would of course update you with the
fresh press action during the week as
usual probably wednesday or thursday
and i hope you enjoyed this video so if
you did please don't forget guys to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys